but first we briefly address the story
that the media mob
and democrats are obsessing about
wall-to-wall coverage 48 hours and
counting
yes congresswoman liz cheney was booted
from her gop
leadership position after months of
nonstop
negative uh remarks about trump and
those support
who support him now the media mob and
democrats are treating congresswoman
cheney
like she's some modern-day martyr she is
not
i see liz today you're a hero you
actually gave your first
interview to msdnc nbc the first
exclusive um wow that's the same network
i believe if we go back
yeah it was referring to your dad as a
war criminal and should be tried and a
criminal with halliburton and all sorts
of other allegations you may want to
refresh your memory
too bad as a republican leader you never
showed the same passion fighting
the radical socialist democrats that
bribe iranian mueller's
abandon our ally israel with the same
type of passion
and psychotic rage that you have against
all things donald trump
now my message to you liz is have fun
i'm sure you have to love all the praise
and attention you're receiving but
remember you're receiving it from the
very same people the democrats and the
media
that called your father a war criminal
the very people that
helped put scooter libya i think he's a
friend of yours in jail
and the same people that accused your
dad of numerous
crimes and felonies related to his work
at halliburton
perhaps you've forgotten i have not here
with a quick refresher
might help you remember take a look liz
cheney is not going to go away
um she is going to continue to stand up
for what she believes in
and as long as she is there and as long
as she is as a microphone
she is going to be able to she's going
to say this i'm not going to go away
once upon a time it was just the
liberals who used to scream
war criminal at dick cheney in public
now it's something the whole family can
enjoy
i do commend
lintani for her courage for her
patriotism
and i wish her well uh
perhaps this challenge will make her
stronger i don't know if we go back to
dick cheney darth vader tactics
then um president obama thinks it's not
going to work liz cheney is daring them
to do this daring them she's telling the
truth she's telling the truth and she's
saying fine
kick me out all right liz enjoy the
sanctimonious ranks of the never
trumpers
i'm sure you'll love joe's new green
deal socialism
and his weak appeasement foreign policy
that will make
the world and the united states less
safe and less
less secure let's see how long it takes
before they start trashing you and your
father again
and by the way for the record you were
not canceled you were removed from
leadership
because you put your selfish agenda
ahead of the party's agenda
and the caucus fired you from your
leadership position
for your failure to lead the agenda you
will likely be canceled
but it will be the people of wyoming
that cancel you
but that's not till election day you
have plenty of time to soak in all the
love from democrats and your new friends
in the media
that were so kind and so loving to you
and your family and your dad and your
mom just wonderful people good luck with
your new friends
we turn to a much more important story
and that's joe biden's ongoing gas
crisis
now causing what is dire issues up and
down the entire east coast of the united
states
look at these maps today over 50 percent
of all stations in virginia they ran out
of gas north carolina
70 percent of gas stations out of fuel
georgia 40 percent of stations ran
out of fuel look at this map eric
erickson tweeted out earlier
today this is atlanta those red dots
there
yeah they show how many stations don't
have any gasoline
multiple states florida tennessee
alabama d.c
and about a half a dozen others also
experiencing serious
shortages tonight meanwhile extremely
long lines
forming at the stations that still had
fuel joe biden didn't want to talk about
it he was too worried and concerned he'd
get in trouble
if he answered too many questions and
his staff threatened i guess not to give
him his hot cocoa before his afternoon
nappy take a look
what's your take on the end of your
meeting sir were you optimistic coming
out of it today
[Music]
joe who are you going to get in trouble
with joey i know you
you forget try and remember if you work
really hard you can remember you're the
president
if you practice every day over time you
should be able to recall that at a
moment's notice
let's make that a big goal for the
future now finally when joey addressed
the crisis his remarks were
actually pretty bizarre take a look
president what do you say to americans
who are worried about the supply of gas
at rising prices right now
i think what this shows is that
i think we have to make a
greater investment in education
as it relates to being able to
train and graduate more people
proficient in cyber security
well look what's the one thing people
are concerned about with the gas
gasoline price is going up exactly right
and it matters if you make forty
thousand dollars a year
it matters if you're two family person
that making eighty ninety thousand
dollars two family two wage earners
it matters oh excuse me
anyway apparently the pipeline is coming
back online great
but remember this happened joey because
russia
yeah linked hackers did it to this
country
joe what are you going to do about it
the people in putin's russia what are
you going to do about vladimir your
buddy your friend
did you call him if you didn't maybe you
can enlist hunter to call him
he's friends with russian oligarchs he's
even convinced russian oligarchs to send
millions of dollars with no experience
maybe he can do this job
and russians by the way joe uh they're
shutting down our country
you haven't said a word not a peep joey
not a word
didn't you promise to be tough on russia
now is a good time
every hostile regime in the world sadly
knows that joe
is weak and frail and they also know
what all of you know
that he's a cognitive mess unfortunately
the world
is more dangerous with a weak president
sad but it's true
and now you the american people we are
all paying the price
we'll have to fend for ourselves in a
world put
full of shortages inflation global
turmoil
looks an awful like a lot like jimmy
carter in the 70s all over again
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else